[Música]
Bienvenidos a este especial sobre Cuba
en France 24 Mi nombre es Rafael
perezoquendo este 2022 fue un año
difícil para Cuba un país de 11 millones
de habitantes en lo económico la
pandemia la persistencia del marco
estadounidense y las reformas monetarias
marcaron el día a día de los cubanos a
la complicada situación financiera se le
sumó una serie de eventos meteorológicos
y accidentes que dejaron grandes
pérdidas materiales y víctimas mortales
sin embargo hubo otras noticias más
alentadoras como la aprobación de un
nuevo código de familias que trajo
importantes cambios a la sociedad o la
creación de sus propias vacunas para
controlar el coronavirus
Cuba vive un proceso de Grandes cambios
económicos entre ellos en la marcha del
ordenamiento monetario que implicó el
cese de la circulación legal de la
moneda libremente convertible un dinero
paralelo Estatal conocido como se usa la
eliminación de subsidios excesivos
gratuidades y una modificación en la
distribución de los ingresos esto sumado
a las condiciones internacionales
impactaron duramente en la cotidianidad
de los ciudadanos afectando El Poder
adquisitivo y el acceso a productos
básicos
otro hecho que afectó la situación
económica y social de La Isla fue la
paralización de varias de sus centrales
termoeléctricas produciendo un déficit
en la generación de Electricidad y como
consecuencia largos cortes de corriente
a la población impactando tanto a los
ciudadanos como a las instituciones
estatales el problema aún no se ha
resuelto en su totalidad una serie de
termoeléctricas móviles han ayudado a
restablecer la energía en cierta medida
ante la incertidumbre del pueblo cubano
por los apagones el gobierno comunicó a
través de la televisión Cuáles serían
las labores de recuperación de estas
centrales
plantas como sistema
eléctrico como sistema electromecánico
tienen avería sufren averías sufren
roturas que no siempre se pueden
predecir necesitan mantenimiento
trabajar con crudo nacional que es
fuertemente contaminante produce sobre
todo en las calderas de estas plantas
muchas incrustaciones y por eso se
requieren mantenimiento sumado el
problema eléctrico el suministro de
combustible necesario para entre otras
cosas arrancar las termoeléctricas se
vio afectado tras el incendio a una
instalación de tanques de almacenamiento
de combustible en la provincia de
matanzas cada uno con una capacidad de
50.000 metros cúbicos el equivalente a
unas 15 piscinas olímpicas el siniestro
dejó 16 personas fallecidas en el
trágico incendio se perdieron al menos
145.000 metros cúbicos de combustible
este accidente perjudicó distintas áreas
económicas y sociales del país las
pérdidas se contabilizaron en unos 66
millones de dólares el gobierno cubano
anunció la del sitio con la ayuda de
Venezuela quien brindará su experiencia
y medios para lograrlo la base ha
seguido funcionando con sus limitación
ahora tenemos menos capacidad de
almacenamiento de Cruz pero no hemos
dejado de dar el servicio con un
esfuerzo inmenso de que tenemos que
seguir trabajando para recuperarlo
afortunado ocurrido durante el año fue
la explosión del Hotel Saratoga uno de
los más emblemáticos de La Habana el
estallido sacudió la zona del Capitolio
nacional cercano al Hostal el presidente
cubano descartó que el hecho fuese
provocado tras varios días de trabajo
entre los escombros el saldo final de
víctimas fue de 47 fallecidos Y al menos
151 lesionados las autoridades señalaron
como causas de la explosión fallas en el
proceso de abastecimiento de gas al
edificio por parte de un carro cisterna
además de los accidentes y los daños en
las termoeléctricas El paso del huracán
agravó los apagones provocando muestras
de descontento popular
dijeron que ese problema no lo iban a
resolver el lunes y Hoy es jueves
entonces la comida que hay que hacer
cola para comprar después no iba a echar
a perder nosotros las mujeres decidimos
salir a la calle empoderando y protestar
para que nos pusieran la corriente no
había necesidad que uno se tirara por la
calle para que vinieran a ponernos
electricidad ante el período difícil el
presidente cubano pidió disculpas al
pueblo un hecho inédito en los últimos
años
quiero decirlo hoy ante ustedes que
representan al pueblo de Cuba y a todos
los que nos escuchen siente un enorme
insatisfacción por no haber sido capaz
de lograr desde la conducción del país
los resultados que necesita el pueblo
cubano para alcanzar la anhelada y
esperaba prosperidad
entre tanto dos hechos positivos
marcaron la vida de los cubanos uno de
ellos la aprobación de un nuevo código
de familia y la inoculación masiva con
vacunas nacionales para mantener a muy
bajos niveles la pandemia del covid
repasemos estos hechos la aprobación de
este nuevo código familiar en el país a
través de un referendo regula y permite
entre otras cosas el consentimiento
legal del matrimonio igualitario la
adopción por parte de parejas del mismo
sexo y la gestación solidaria el nuevo
código de familia deroga el aprobado en
1975 a pesar del corte progresista de la
medida muchos estuvieron en contra Sin
embargo los nuevos preceptos fueron
con el
66,87% de los votos
Cuba creó cinco candidatos vacunales de
los cuales tres fueron inoculados a la
población repasemos los cinco candidatos
soberana cero dos soberana 01 soberana
Plus abdala y mambisa el sistema de
salud de la República de Cuba administró
las vacunas unas 42 millones
639.680 dosis hasta este 17 de diciembre
diez millones dos mil novecientos
setenta y nueve cubanos cuentan con un
esquema completo de vacunación y más de
ocho millones con dosis de refuerzo esto
según datos del Ministerio de salud
pública de Cuba y hasta aquí este
especial sobre Cuba un año difícil
gracias por acompañarnos continúen
[Música]